[Musik]
[Applaus]
eingekeilt zwischen europa nordafrika
und zentralasien und der nahe osten ist
zweifelsohne einer der heißesten
geopolitischen hotspots ob es um
energieversorgung religion terrorismus
korruption oder kriege geht der nahe
osten steht immer im rampenlicht wir
sprechen von einem ort der dem westen
geografisch ebenso nahe steht die eher
sozial politisch und kulturell von ihm
entfernt ist in dieser unruhigen
regionen gibt es jedoch eine erstaunlich
stabile gruppe von ländern die ein
gemeinsames ziel haben die geschicke der
islamischen welt zu lenken ein
gemeinsames ziel welches sie aber mit
sehr unterschiedlichen methoden
verfolgen konkret geht es zwei große
gruppen saudi arabien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate auf der
einen und katar und die türkei auf der
anderen seite
[Musik]
das bündnis zwischen partei und der
türkei stellt dabei das allerneuste
große würden bis dar das in dieser
unruhigen regierung der welt geschmiedet
wurde denn abgesehen vom iran ist die
rivalität zwischen diesen beiden großen
gruppen so enorm dass man fast schon von
einem wirklich schaffen konflikt
sprechen könnte dem kalten krieg der
islamischen welt so war der brutale mord
mit dem die emirate oder andere
arabische staaten katars zwischen 2017
und 2019 abgestraft haben vielleicht das
prominenteste beispiel aber bei weitem
nicht die einzige aktion in diesen
muslimischen game of thrones in real
life aber wieso springt ausgerechnet die
türkei nun tat zur seite worauf genau
sie das bündnis zwischen der türkei und
katar und vielleicht die wichtigste
frage von allen warum positioniert sich
erdogan nun so klar gegen die beiden
mächtigsten monaten am persischen golf
welche interessen verfolgt er heute da
all diese spannenden und hochgradig
aktuellen fragen beantworten zuvor
müssten aber noch etwas geld mit werbung
verdienen um versprochen zu rift
informative videos produzieren zu können
und dieses geld bekommen wir von unserem
sponsor zu aktivieren der serc ist ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass weder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit locken außerdem
jede menge security tools mitbringt
verschafft es aber auch aus vielen
anderen gründen ein ganz tolles dpa
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe
auch webseite und internet dienste
zugreifen in dem land in dem ihr gerade
seiten ist verfügbar sind ohne zensur
und tier blocking ob daheim oder im
urlaub darüber hinaus bietet es jedoch
weitere sicherheits-features habt ihr
nicht zum beispiel auch ein mulmiges
gefühl durch die allgegenwärtigen und er
will pop ups und cookies mailserver hat
bekommt ein handliches tool namens clean
web dass sie alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem schlag
konnte könnt ihr alle eure geräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks und sogar
euren smart tvs deckt wirklich alle
arten von geräten ab ihr bekommt damit
einen lückenlosen schutz so und weil wir
euch unsere treuen fans lieb haben waren
wir nur bereit diese sponsoring zu
übernehmen wenn euch search lag auch an
den ordentlichen rabatt eingeräumt und
das ist uns gelungen mit hilfe des
rabattes politik.de bekommt ihr sage und
schreibe 83 prozent rabatt und obendrein
noch die ersten vier monate gratis dazu
den link zu diesem angebot findet ihr in
der beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt server und greift
damit gleichzeitig auch uns finanziell
unter die arme so und nun ab in den
nahen osten an den bosporus und den
persischen golf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so wie es aussieht ist die islamische
welt derart komplex dass die für
diejenigen von uns die nicht dazugehören
kaum zu durchschauen ist wollen wir
jedoch wenigstens ansatzweise versuchen
die politische landkarte so gut ist wie
zu vereinfachen kommen wir nicht umher
uns mit den zwei größten sekten im islam
auseinanderzusetzen dem schiff muss der
vor allem im iran verbreitet ist aus dem
solis muss der im grunde die vorherigen
der ausrichtung der restlichen
muslimischen welt darstellt und wenn wir
das ganze weiter herunter brechen und
uns den nahen osten von der sunnitischen
seite aus ansehen finden wir zwei große
politische religiöse blöcke vor den
islamischen block um den block der
absolutistischen monarchie dazwischen
gibt es einige länder die auf beiden
seiten spielen natürlich verschiedene
aufständische gruppen ebenfalls auf
beiden seiten
[Musik]
der islamische blog wird vor allem von
katar und der türkei eingeführt und die
politische rebellen aktion die von
diesen ländern finanziert gefördert und
auf jede erdenkliche weise unterstützt
wird ist als muslim bruderschaft bekannt
eine organisation die in dieser ganzen
geschichte eine schlüsselrolle spielt
die gruppe der absoluten monarchie saudi
arabien und den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten geführt auch wenn bachrain oft
dazu gezählt wird und durch
zugehörigkeit und bündnisse auch ägypten
auf jeden fall sind dies die beiden
bündnisse welche die turco arabische
politik derzeit in der mitte spalten
aber wofür genau stehen die jeweiligen
gruppen was genau bringt sie
gegeneinander auf und seien wir ehrlich
eine weitere wichtige frage warum sollte
uns das ganze überhaupt interessieren
[Musik]
nun einerseits ist der radikale
beziehungsweise politische islam von
vielen auch als islamismus bezeichnet
eine theorie die eine art sogenannte
islamische demokratie als wesentliches
politisches system unterstützt ihr
größter vertreter es die muslim
bruderschaft eine supranationale und
ultra konservative organisationen die
der ehemalige präsident donald trump als
terroristische vereinigung einstufen
ließ auch in deutschland zum beispiel
der verfassungsschutz nordrhein
westfalens eine unvereinbarkeit des
gedankenguts der muslim brüder mit dem
deutschen grundgesetz festgestellt die
muslim bruderschaft wird hauptsächlich
von katar finanziert und von der türkei
unterstützt diese organisation wiederum
finanziert berät und arbeitet mit
radikal- islamischen parteien in weiten
teilen der muslimischen welt zusammen
ihr ziel ist die durchsetzung der
scharia und ihrer besonderen vision
eines politischen islamismus der in der
praxis jedoch mit regimes von ländern
wie zum beispiel saudi arabien
kollidiert
aber damit wir uns nicht falsch
verstehen wenn wir voll islamische
demokratie sprechen hat das fast nichts
mit demokratie zu tun also ich meine
jene freiheitlich pluralistische
demokratie welche das gesellschaftliche
ideale aufgeklärten welt darstellt daher
müssen wir sie immer in
anführungszeichen sehen denn was der
politische islam unter demokratie
versteht ist nichts anderes als dass
politik und staat die zentrale aufgabe
haben eine brutale religiöse
interpretation des lebens der gesetze
und der institutionen in der ganzen
gesellschaft durchzusetzen eines der
probleme die sich daraus ergeben ist der
direkte einfluss von imamen und in
vielen fällen von sehr radikalen namen
im gegensatz dazu steht die theorie
saudi arabiens und der vereinigten
arabischen emirate deren politisches
system jeweils auf einer königlichen
familie basiert die in der lage sein
soll den religiösen radikalismus mehr
oder weniger unter kontrolle zu halten
und genau dieses prinzip verteidigt
mohammed bin sajid seines zeichens
grundprinzip abu dhabi und de facto
herrscher der vereinigten arabischen
emirate er ist derzeit wahrscheinlich
der mächtigste arabische führer der welt
tatsache ist dass laut bin seit die
arabische gesellschaft heute nicht reif
für echte demokratie ist da die öffnung
zur welt nur vom autoritären regimes
geführt werden kann nach ansicht dieses
politischen führers wurde die förderung
demokratischer tendenzen nur
fundamentalistische gruppen nähren die
am ende die wahlen gewinnen würden wie
du dir vorstellen kannst denn sowohl die
regierungen der v als auch saudi
arabiens erbitterte feinde der muslim
bruderschaft und nicht nur das da der
katarische türkischen blog diese
politisch islamistische organisation
fördert und schützt sind reibungen und
flickte und angespannte situation
zwischen den beiden blöcken an der
tagesordnung und weißt du was genau an
dieser stelle fällt die ganze geschichte
an so richtig interessant zu werden also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein bündnis uns alles vernichten
an dieser stelle unseres videos müssen
wir uns eine frage stellen die uns wohl
alle beschäftigt woher kommt überhaupt
die freundschaft zwischen zwei
geografisch zu weit entfernten ländern
wie der türkei und katar welche
interessen teilen sie nun es muss gesagt
werden dass diese beziehung schon viel
früher begangen als er denken nämlich
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts zu
dieser zeit wurde katar teil des
osmanischen reiches aber das aktuelle
bündnis hat damit natürlich nicht viel
zu tun
die enge türkisch katarische verbindung
vollführte einen großen sprung nach
vorne als 2002 die partei für
gerechtigkeit und entwicklung akp der
türkei an die macht kam und die
islamistische partei von recep tayyip
erdogan hat eine ganz andere vision als
die von atatürk gegründeten cool ehre
türkei die du dir vorstellen kannst war
die muslim bruderschaft der akp ziemlich
sympathisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und tatsächlich sind die beziehungen
zwischen den beiden organisationen seit
er immer enger geworden und wie wir nun
wissen ist der hauptsponsor finanzier
und förderer der muslimbruderschaft wer
genau katar
[Musik]
aber vorsicht denn dieses politische
ideologische motiv ist nicht das einzige
welches die türkei und katar näher
gebracht hat als nächstes müssen wir uns
nämlich mit rds persönlichen ambitionen
auseinandersetzen denn diese sind längst
kein geheimnis mehr auch wenn er über
viele jahre hinweg sein wahres gesicht
nicht zeigen wollte um erstmal schön
europa an der nase herumzuführen der
türkische führer träumt davon die türkei
zur story tischen großmacht in der
europäischen welt zu machen einstellung
die sich derzeit auf die arabien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate teilen
und aus diesem grund steckt erdogan nun
seine tentakel aus bis an den persischen
golf denn dort bietet sich ihnen nur ein
einziges land an katar das rebellische
schwarze schaf der arabischen halbinsel
hat erdogan aber nicht auch jahrelang so
getan als wolle er die türkei zu einem
mitglied der europäischen union machen
sogar mariano rajoy der ehemalige
konservative präsident spaniens hat
einmal eine kundgebung zugunsten von
erdogan besucht
landet machte einweihung einer u bahn
linien ankara auf einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung von erdogans
islamistische partei wie um alles in der
welt soll die türkei also die große
politische macht der muslimischen welt
werden und gleichzeitig teil der
einflussreichsten supranationalen
organisationen des westens nun genau an
dieser stelle beginnt das doppelte spiel
dass erdogan praktisch seit seiner
machtübernahme im jahr 2003 gespielt hat
und zu einem gewissen grad immer noch
spielt
[Musik]
damals gelang es sowohl der türkei als
auch katar sich im westen als zwei
vorbilder ist ein modell für
modernisierung und offenheit in der
muslimischen welt darzustellen die
türkei wurde von den europäern als
lebender beweis dafür angesehen dass ein
land mit einer muslimischen mehrheit
eine echte konsolidierte demokratie
werden kann und genau dieser umstand
verlieh ihr eine wichtige internationale
rolle auf diese weise wurde sie zum
beispiel zum vermittler bei einigen der
schwerwiegendsten konflikte in diesem
teil der welt auch katar wurde
seinerseits der hauptverbindungen der
hauptbrücke zwischen im westen und
einigen radikal-islamischen
aufständischen gruppen sowie
tyrannischen regierungen aller art
katarer zum beispiel an vermittlungen
zwischen der hamas fatah um dem staat
israel zwischen saddam hussein und den
vereinigten staaten unsere libanon unter
hisbollah gruppe teilgenommen neben
vielen anderen gruppen und wurde der
deal zwischen den afghanischen taliban
und der us-regierung eingefädelt genau
in doha der hauptstadt katars freund
genau auf diese weise wurde doha zu
diplomatischen hauptstadt des nahen
ostens und der arabischen welt insgesamt
das letzte herausragende beispiel war
die verhandlungen zwischen der tramp
administration und den taliban bei der
der rückzug der usa aus afghanistan
vereinbart wurde alles lief reibungslos
und mit vollgas so sehr dass die türkei
und katar eine zeitlang die
lehrbuchbeispiel für ihrer form und
demokratie fähige islamische
gesellschaften erschienen auf der einen
seite gewann die türkei dann katar an
einfluss und politischem gewicht auf der
anderen seite erhielt katar den schutz
eines militärischen riesen welcher der
nato angehört und genau hier wissen wir
einen kleinen exkurs machen katar lebt
seit jeher mit der paranoia das ist
jeden tag von den saudis überfallen
werden könnte denn seien wir ehrlich die
beziehungen zwischen diesen beiden
ländern sind seit jeher grauenhaft
es gab sogar etwas das als kataris
saudischer stellvertreter krieg bekannt
geworden ist eine art kalter krieg oder
latenter klick in die jedes land proxies
benutzte um die drecksarbeit des anderen
zu erledigen wir sprechen hier von
terror banken politischen parteien und
religiösen bewegungen die für diese art
der drecksarbeit zuständig waren aber
natürlich ist katar ist viel viel
kleiner ist und dass immer die
befürchtung bestand dass saudi arabien
eines tages einfach seinem schicken
würde um das nervigen ära zur räson zu
bringen und um genau das zu verhindern
brauchte katar einen ideologischen
verbündeten der groß gerade die
freistunde militärisch stark war und wer
war sich dafür nicht zu schade genauer
dorns türkei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zunächst wirkten die beiden ja auch wie
ein traumpaar allem ehrlich gelangen ist
katar und der türkei sich als eine art
vermittler zwischen bestimmten teilen
der muslimischen welt zu positionieren
aber 2011 wollten sie einen schritt
weiter gehen und eine viel aktivere
rolle in der islamischen geopolitik
spielen damals begann sie millionen aber
millionen von dollar zu investieren um
alle arten von aufständischen bewegungen
revolutionären gruppen und sogar gruppen
die von einem großen teil der
internationalen gemeinschaft als
terroristen angesehen werden zu
unterstützen
ihr ziel anderer muslimische länder zu
stabilisieren die dortigen regierungen
zu stürzen und sie durch
radikalislamische parteien die der
muslim-bruderschaft treu sind zu
ersetzen wir sprechen unter anderem von
gruppen wie der hisbollah und der hamas
und jetzt fragt ihr euch sicher was das
ergebnis dieser bemühungen war nun das
ergebnis könnt ihr bereits allerdings
verbindet ihr es nun mit einer ganz
anderen ursache und ganz anderen
urhebern zb mit barack obama und hillary
clinton fällt der groschen exakt das
ergebnis der türkisch katarischen
usurpation war nichts geringeres als der
sogenannte arabische frühling dieser
stand im grunde aus einer reihe von
revolten die sich in der gesamten
arabischen welt ausbreiteten und im
westen als volksaufstand gegen
despotisch und korrupte herrscher fehl
interpretiert wurden
alles deutet jedoch darauf hin dass
diese aufstände von katar und der türkei
gefördert und finanziert wurden und
tatsächlich setzten sie so viele
ressourcen ein oder erfolg war so groß
dass die herrscher von saudi arabien und
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
ersthaft ist schwitzen kam hören sie die
nächsten sein und deswegen bildeten die
monarchin am persischen golf zu denen
sich kurz darauf auch bahrain und
ägypten gesellten ein viererbündnis das
nahost quartett bekannt wurde
dieses quartett erklärte katar und die
türkei sofort vor einer bedrohung sowohl
für die regionale politik als auch für
ihre eigenen interessen von diesem
moment an wurde katar immer mehr von
seinen nachbarn isoliert und auch
zunehmend bedroht es ist immer
abhängiger der türkei machte und
erinnerst du nicht an den putsch
versuchen der türkei im jahr 2016 nun es
ist immer noch nicht klar wann
inszeniert hat es gibt theorien es hätte
sich um eine fos fleck operation
erdogans gehandelt oder dass die
türkische bewegung um den prediger
kühlen dahinter steckt aber vieles
deutet darauf hin dass der putsch von
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
unterstützt wurde mit dem ziel erkoren
zu stürzen
nach östliche unterstützer des
gescheiterten putschversuchs in der
türkei ein jahr später ist die
verwicklung der vg und ägyptens in den
gescheiterten putschversuch in der
türkei offensichtlicher als je zuvor und
obwohl erdogans masterplan in der praxis
wie ein diplomatischer und politischer
fehlschlag erscheinen mag hat erdogan in
wirklichkeit bekommen was er wollte die
großen arabischen pedro monarchien zu
kontern und selbst eine bedeutende
politische und sogar militärische
präsenz am persischen golf zu erreichen
und tatsache ist dass diese situation so
gewaltige spannung erzeugte dass die
konsequenzen nicht lange auf sich warten
ließen juli 2017 fünf arabische staaten
wollen katar isolieren und bringen die
usa in bedrängnis
arabische mächte listen 59 personen auf
die mit katar in verbindung stehen und
den terrorismus unterstützen die
sanktionen gegen katar haben das inserat
jedoch nicht dazu gebracht sich zu
ändern sondern die dortige
herrscherfamilie al thani noch weiter in
erdogans arme getrieben und natürlich
auch in die eines anderen erzfeind audi
arabiens katar stellt volle beziehungen
zum iran wieder her und vertieft den
golf konflikt natürlich hat katar
wirtschaftlich unter den sanktionen
gelitten aber wir reden hier von einem
land das verdammt reich ist ein
führender katarischer banker hat es so
ausgedrückt jeder von uns kann sich
daheim nun nicht mehr fünf sondern nur
noch drei dienste zu leisten tatsache
ist dass die sanktionen uns war der
vergangenheit angehören die spannungen
zwischen den beiden blöcken aber weiter
bestehen aber lasst uns an dieser stelle
die politischen und strategischen
aspekte beiseite legen und uns ein
bisschen mehr auf die zahlen auf den
wirtschaftlichen teil konzentrieren
welche auswirkungen hat er diese ganze
geschichte auch die wirtschaftskraft der
beteiligten akteure beim geld hört ja
bekanntlich alle freundschaft auf
schauen wir uns also das doch mal etwas
genauer an
[Musik]
jeder gefallen hat seinen preis
die wirtschaftlichen beziehungen
zwischen der türkei und katar haben seit
der gründung des bündnisses im jahr 2002
zugenommen aber nicht unbedingt so wie
du es dir vielleicht vorstellen magst
interessanterweise ist der handel der
türkei mit saudi arabien und den
emiraten stärker gewachsen als mit katar
denn was hier zählt ist einfach nur die
pure größe
natürlich ist das nicht die ganze
geschichte
katar und die türkei haben wichtige
abkommen über tourismus investitionen
und verteidigung unterzeichnet vor allem
im verteidigungsbereich wurden wichtige
rüstungsverträge abgeschlossen darüber
hinaus hat katar keinen moment gezögert
als einen verbündeten in jeder krise
wirtschaftlich zu unterstützen welche
die türkische wirtschaft und währung die
türkische lira seit 2008 zehn
durchmachen
um die eine vorstellung von der
größenordnung zu geben über die
widersprechen katar hat zwischen 2018
und ende 2009 10 und 20 milliarden
dollar zur rettung der türkischen
wirtschaft beigetragen und das ist noch
nicht alles mit dem 2020 mitten in der
korona krise unterzeichnete katar ein
währungs swap abkommen mit der türkei in
höhe von 15 milliarden dollar um die
finanzen der regierung erdogan zu
sanieren in der praxis gehen viele
experten davon aus dass diese
wirtschaftshilfe nichts anderes als eine
art ausgleich für den schutz ist den die
türkei qatar gewährt aber wartet denn
das ist nur die spitze des eisbergs
[Musik]
in wirtschaftlicher militärischer
hinsicht hat qatar seit 2017 zahlreiche
türkische rüstungsgüter erworben und
nicht nur das die kataris haben auch
kredite an die türkische militär
industrie vergeben und 100 millionen
dollar in bmc einem der führenden
türkischen hersteller gepanzerter
fahrzeuge investiert so ist katar
immerhin der drittgrößte waffenexporteur
der welt in den letzten jahren zu einem
wichtigen kunden der türkischen
rüstungsindustrie geworden eine
wertvolle unterstützung in einer für die
türkischen wirtschaft und türkische
unternehmen sehr schwierigen zeit
[Musik]
manche würden sogar sagen dass katar die
türkei eine lebensretter ist denn die
türkische wirtschaft und vor allem die
währung liegen wirklich auf der
intensivstation
wir haben bereits vor gut zwei jahren
anfang 2020 in einem video vorhergesagt
dass die türkische lira abschlossen wird
und seitdem hat sich ihr wert bis zum
zeitpunkt des drehs dieses videos
gegenüber euro und dollar mehr als
halbiert viele haben uns damals in den
kommentaren dafür beschimpft aber wer
damals auf uns gehört hat konnte da
schon eines fetten gewinn einfahren
vergisst also bitte nicht wieso politik
zu abonnieren falls auch in zukunft
keine unserer test sicheren prognosen
lassen möchte ist übrigens bevor wir zum
schluss kommen dürfen wir eines nicht
vergessen als teil ihres schutzschirms
hat die türkei eine eigene militärbasis
in doha der hauptstadt von katar
eröffnet ein stützpunkt der ein
ständiges kontingent von 5.000
türkischen soldaten beherbergen soll du
siehst also dass da im nahen osten eine
wirklich große und langfristige alias
entstanden ist ein bündnis das auf allen
ebenen von dauer zu sein scheint wir
werden euch in verruf darüber natürlich
weiter informiert zum beispiel auch im
zusammenhang mit der in katar
stattfinden fußball dm aber jetzt bist
du erst mal an der reihe was meinst du
könnte es zu einer offenen militärischen
konflikt zwischen der türkei und den
beiden arabischen großmächten am
persischen golf kommen wird katar
weiterhin gruppen wie die
muslim-bruderschaft unterstützen und
welche rolle spielt dabei europa wird
ist der unterwanderung seiner
demokratischen gesellschaften durch die
in der türkei und katar finanzierten
radikalislamischen organisationen
endlich wirksam entgegentreten kann es
dabei mit der unterstützung des hauses
rechnen die mit den salafisten ja viele
jahre ihre eigene radikalen gruppe
unterhielten dna sind wir auf alle eure
meinungen zu diesem thema schon gespannt
ich hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls jahr gibt es mit
einem leicht eilsen und freunden und
vergesst mich das abo mit glöckchen und
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
was gut und bis bald
[Musik]